good motivation my name is Evan
Carmichael by one word is believed and I
believe that not burgers will solve all
of the world's major problems some of
your journey today's message is ask
great questions over to you Timothy
Ferriss I find that levels of success in
almost any industry or area correlate to
a person asking great questions in some
cases they seem absurd in fact the
hallmarking way of great questions is
that sound completely ridiculous so
someone might ask why peter thiel why
can't you achieve your 10 year goals in
the next six months there's a thought
exercise that's like--that's that's a
good question to answer for yourself and
these types of questions come up
surprisingly often with with very very
impressive folks whether it's in
business military entertainment or
otherwise and the way you can get better
at questions is by studying interviews
in part so I studied Larry King
I studied Charlie Rose I studied Terry
Gross I studied that that go down the
list
I studied Tony Robbins who does in
person one-on-one interventions at his
events in front of ten thousand five
thousand people and he's just genius
with how he uses questions to like
pattern interrupt and grab someone's
attention and divert them in a more
productive productive direction now why
is that relevant relevant because
thinking is the process of asking
questions you're asking yourself
questions and then you're answering them
in your own head so if you get better at
asking other people questions you get
better at asking yourself questions
which means you are a you're improving
your thought performance and level of
thinking what am I to do both for my
self approach Bruce
with is trying to turn limiting
statements into how questions turn
limiting statements into how questions
so as an example turn a statement like I
can't do this because I have a full-time
job into a how do I do this while I have
a full-time job I can't start this
company because I don't have any money
into how do I start this business
without having any money as soon as you
can move from eliminate statement that
you absorb and feel like well this is
just true I have a limiting life I have
limited resources I have limited access
I'm limited everything is aluminum that
we achieve anything so as you move to
that state to a how how do I accomplish
it with these restrictions limitations
then you start to break out your box
then you start to have the ability to do
more amazing things and so it's catching
yourself to know when you're saying
really limiting statements and then
asking that question of how can I
accomplish it except these limitations
that I have right now part of the
challenge though is catching yourself
and knowing when you're actually seeing
a living statement because again so much
a bit of subconscious so much of the
time they're just automatic been living
on a small loan automatically living on
autopilot you know living living by
other people's expectations and
limitations
constant we're not constant going off
living big doing huge things we're
living in survival mode so often so we
know that capsules of these statements
can be difficult here's one of my
favorite exercises on how to fix it look
at yourself in the mirror
go do it look yourself in the mirror
pull up your phone and let yourself on
the phone and ask yourself why am I not
more successful why have I not get my
goals why have I had this goal for the
past three years and they haven't made
progress why is it still up something
going why have I not done the thing that
I said I want to do that she's important
to me why haven't I thought and some
worry there is going to be an answer
right like don't look the way to get an
answer and then from there that's when
you're limiting say that's probably the
most powerful oh I see
yeah well I'm not able to be a success I
haven't my goals because I didn't go to
university and everybody who has success
went to university right that's the
story that you kind of replay over and
over and over and over and over getting
your mind
great that's the living statement let's
turn that into out how do I accomplish
my goal in Suffern business without
having university education how do I
surround myself with resources and
people who prove to me that it's
possible to go up and do this because
lots of entrepreneurs it done right so I
find that exercise so huh look at
yourself in the mirror or write it down
on a piece of paper
I have not accomplished my big goals yet
because already down maybe there's
multiple reasons 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 if you
fill up the whole page of reasons why
you're not more successful why you
haven't hit your goals each one of those
are limiting statements and as long as
you continue to believe them as long as
you can continue to act by them most of
the times subconsciously it's not like
you every day wake up and just remind
you something I haven't I don't have to
be the recipient so I can be successful
it's not like you have these negative
mantras you just do it automatically
it's how you're living your life by
default the limitations are hard to
catch this is just a default so if you
build your list of the reasons and then
started talking them ask yourself how
questions as soon as you ask yourself
how how can I instead of just accepting
this negative situation the Box Excel
open the possibility is there to open
you move from a negative place to a
positive one you move from a resource
list state to a resourceful one because
you're forcing your brain into the
question how can I do this despite not
having this and despite being this
despite growing up like this how can I
still go up and do it and if you get
used to asking those potential filled
questions then you bring co-financing
you're asking better questions
living a really limited life but for the
most part is self-imposed so the
question today is I like the coupe to go
through this exercise with you ask
yourself what is the one reason just
pick one second the other useless what
is one reason why you're not more
successful by you having accomplished
two main goals write it down the cost
below and the next to it right now the
how-to version of it how can i version
of it and if you really want to take it
the next step
answer that question into the how to
think if you do that consistently it
open up a world of difference for you
and love the spark right here on this
episode so live it down the console with
all really good see what you have the
same I also want to give a quick ship to
Mike Phillips Mike thank you so much a
bit of a cup of my book your one word I
really appreciate the support Mike and I
hope you enjoyed the book so thank you
guys so much for watching I believe in
you continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one where it is
much love and I'll see you again
tomorrow morning for another shot of
espresso
[Music]
how would you tell us to develop a habit
of curiosity well you know what people
do look at me and see me as creative
because I've written so many books and I
am curious but when I started off in
college in in my in my freshman psych
class they gave us a test that it for
each student to take on creativity and
there were 17 in that class I can
remember it well and I was at the bottom
of the class on creativity I mean I was
like number 17 out of 17 and and and
what the teacher posted the scores and
so I mean I saw how bad I was it and
then I really felt bad not only because
I wasn't creative but I was going to go
pastor I was going to go in the minister
I was gonna teach I was going to do
sermons and then I got to thinking to
myself I'm going to be another boring
preacher and you know I said just
gripping I thought oh this is gonna be
awful I'm gonna bore people all my life
you know what I mean and I'm going to
ask him to pay while they hear me I mean
this is an awful deal so it and so two
things I did and I talked about in the
book one as I started filing I started
taking thoughts and quotes and the
reason I started doing that is I thought
if I'm not going to be good at what I
say I need to quote somebody that is
good and so I started filing things that
other people would say so I'd go around
and I'd say well Ken said you know what
I mean and Joe said and Suzy said and so
that at least I would be a little bit
more interesting and that's how it
started but the big breakthrough the big
breakthrough ahead was and this will
help everyone if how many of you would
like to be more creative let me let me
see your hands okay how many of you'd
like to just absolutely have an
imagination that just took you to a new
level you know I'm sorry okay
how many I already have that because
you're on drugs okay okay okay well
here's here's here's the key this will
work for you I promise it'll work for
you because it worked for me I made a
major change in my early 30s from just
having answers and being a leader that
just had to cast vision and show
everybody what I was doing and where we
were going and I started asking
intentional questions and I became a
person I asked questions all the time
every day I asked questions and I have
found just asking questions we'll take
you on exciting journeys more than
anything else your Verrett you excel in
that kid now
watched you over the years you'd Excel
really in that but for my early years I
didn't ask enough questions and so
therefore I didn't get enough ideas and
thoughts from others
so when people say I want to be more
creative what's step one step number one
is ask more questions just go to people
and start asking questions it's amazing
what you learn I'm obsessed with this
idea of no standard terms so when we
when we were first getting started and
took took financing or our lawyers would
take us through the documents and they'd
say oh you don't worry about it it's all
standard then at the time I'm like oh
sure Sandra that's great
no no issues no problem and I've since
learned that standard means either the
person who's walking you through the
documents doesn't understand them or you
could be getting taken advantage of
when someone said something standard
just ask why and why and why and why
until you really understand you know
intricately I think how how the deal
structured and so I I think the big
thing that we took away from that is you
know standard terms is a huge red flag
and beyond that just afraid to just
continue asking why